Qu'est-ce que les gens pensent et cherchent sur moi
Ouais je suis la mode ouais je commence mes vidéos sans être devant la caméra
Aujourd'hui
Cette chaise me péte les c*****e
Les amis aujourd'hui, on va faire un truc que j'ai jamais fait
mais qui a déjà était fait par tous les gens
de, d'internet
On va se "Google-ler"
se "google-liser"
Appellez ça comme vous voulez
On va voir ce que les gens veulent savoir sur moi
on va voir ce que les gens disent sur moi
On va flatter mon égo comme jamais
Déjà t'es un mec qui pèse quand quand tu tapes la 1ère lettre de ton pseudo
sur Google
ça te sort ton pseudo en 1er
*musique triste*
De toute façon Yahoo c'est mieux
c'est grave mieux
Voilà l'égo est brisé
c'est bon
On peut avancer
sq
aaaaaaaaaaaah ( bruit de satisfaction )
( bruit bizarre)
Bon, les blagues sur l'égo sont terminées
Parce qu'il fallait les faire
fallait passer par là
Squeezie
Squeezie Youtube
c'est plutôt correct
Squeezie the last guardian
ça fait plaisir!!
On est heureux de voir que les gens ont entendu parler du let's play
et ont voulu le trouver
En tapant "squeezie the last guardian" sur Google
"squeezie quotidien"
aaaaaaaaaaaaah
oui
Vous voulez dire
Je vous l'amène avec modestie
Voilà désolé
Il est encore plein de poussière
c'est que mes trophées
Je m'en fous
je je , j'en tiens pas compte
"squeezie twitter"
Bah tu tapes "squeezie" dans Twitter
ça va plus vite aussi
"squeezie age"
c'est une très bonne question
Quel âge a Squeezie?
Il a 21 ans
Il est né le 27 janvier 96
"Le vrai âge de squeezie"
c'est quoi ça...
"Et bien salut tout le monde c'est MOCROB
on se retrouve pour une nouvelle vidéo
sur 'How-Old.net'
Là par exemple on va commencer avec le 1er
ah vous voyez hein?
Vous voyez j'ai déjà essayé
Heuuu...
Sauf qu'en faite c'était pour voir si ça marchait ou pas.."
(rire)
Oh non!!
Le mec s'est fait grillé par son historique, p****n
"Et en faite j'ai une photo c'est celle là.."
Alors quel âge, quel âge j'ai?
"On va faire une prédiction
Moi je pense en vrai il a"
12 ans
"23 ans"
( bruit de pet)
What de f**k!!
Mon dieu!!
42 p****n de m***e
Ouais mais après les mecs plus vieux
Les filles, elles aiment bien..
Bon on dirait vraiment que j'ai 12 ans
(rire)
Bon alors!!
"squeezie salaire"
ouiiii
L'argent des abonnés et alors...
"Selon les Echos Squeezie est en tête avec 480k d'euros amassés en 1 an
Cyprien engrange 360 000
et Norman ferme la marche comme il l'a indiqué avec
100 000 euros touchés
Ce qui est excellent c'est qu'il l'a jamais indiquééé
Est-ce qu'un jour Norman a fait une vidéo ou il fait
"Bonjour à tous
je touche 100 000 euros par an
maintenant on va parler des chats,euh..."
Et bah nan
et bah nan il l'a jamais dit
J'sais plus l'histoire exacte mais c'est dans une émission
ils lui ont posé la question
Il était en mode "malaise"
Comme quand tu demandes à n'importe quelle personne au monde
combien il gagne sur un plateau télé devant
300 000 personnes
Et il avait eu une réponse je sais plus trop quoi..
Ouais et les médias ont fait
"Ok il gagne 100 000 euros c'est bon il l'a dit"
FAUX!!!!
Ironie du sort..
480 000 euros p****n...
Et le mec est pas foutu d'acheter une vrai pipe
P****N!!!
Bouygues
Votre facture est toujours impayée
pour la régler RDV sur votre espace client
480 000  euros par an
Et il paye pas sa facture de téléphone le c*n!
"squeezie taille"
ouuuuuuuh
Attention je crois que sur ce site y'a ma taille..
1m69
Mais nan!!! Mais les mecs vous pouvez lâcher le 70
On passe à la dizaine du dessus
je gagne au moins deux points de virilité
J'chuis sûr qu'ils ont fait ça pour me faire c***r
Ils savent déjà que
le 1er truc qu'on dit quand on va dans la rue
c'est bien évidement ..
Et mais t'es petit en vrai!!!!"
Mais moi j'chuis un bonhomme tu t'en doutes
le mec je peux pas lui laisser me parler comme ça du coup je dis quoi
"Oui t'as vu je suis vraiment petit et pas crédible en vrai"
Voila.. (rire gêné)
Ce site par-contre il est flippant il regroupe ma taille et tout...
J'aime pas du tout
Régularité: 4 vidéos par semaine
C'est vrai
Affiliation : CyprienGaming & Razer
(rire et clap)
C'est trop marrant
Ils comparent un pote avec vraiment une marque qui vend des claviers quoi..
ah Cyprien je l'aurais mal pris à ta place mais bon après ouais..
Son snapchat : squeezielucas
J'chavais même pas, shc, j'chavais même pas
Je crois que j'ai même pas installé snapchat
Ah je tourne euh..
oooooooooooooohhh
Mais regarde en pleine vidéo
Mais qu'est-ce qu'il nous arrive
"Bah ça tourne"
ça va?
T'as vu comment il s'est vénère ?
T'as vu comment il a dit "Oh je tourne là, qu'est-ce qui y'a ?
Là les gens vont me dire
" mais qu'est-ce qu'il se passe?"
Pourquoi Jhon Rachid??
Voilà moi j'interviens dans toutes les vidéos de tout le monde j'en ai rien à foutre
Attends tu veux regarder pour toi??
1er jeu vidéo
Nan moi arrête c'est dégueulasse..
Jhon rachid sniper
Sniper, pourquoi ?
c'est ta vidéo sur Sniper
ah ouais d'accord
donc je dois t'apprendre pourquoi les gens.. "nan c'est bon"
nan ça c'est bien "jcvd" forcement
JCVD, bien sûr
karima
JCVD, est-ce que tu peux me faire un...
JUL !
un p'tit s'il te plait !
un p'tit jcvd
s'il te plaît devant moi s'il te plaît
Imitation réussie de JCVD Bon dans l'air y'a quoi y'a les atomes
Les atomes ca rentre par le nez, hein, les oreilles c'est pas pareil c'est un canal, c'est different si tu connectes les deux t'a le "mind"(l'esprit) et le corps en sante (etc..)
A bientôt jhon!!!
love you<3
Bon on peut reprendre maintenant
"squeezie hanouna" ah ouiiiiii...
Je me souviens de ça quand j'ai parlé d'Hanouna c'était quand...
( cherche quelque chose )
Bon j'ai reçu un Q d'or ouais.
Bon sur YouTube on a quoi
pokemon go
horreur
"squeezie malaise"
malaise étant le mot le plus détesté du monde à l'heure qu'il est
Vous savez quoi remplaçons le par
"génance"
pour changer un peu...
c'est encore pire..
"squeezie baptiste"
Oh j'ai une anecdote incroyable à vous raconter!!!
je suis aller au mondial du..
au salon du, du...
du mondial du tatouage
j'arrive plus à parler bonjour
C'était à Porte de la Villette je crois ou peut-être j'dis une connerie bref.
J'y étais et en me baladant ya un mec qui m'arrête et qui me dis
"Eh euh squeezie"
Et je reconnais sa voix et j'fais "qui es-tu?"
Et là il m'a sorti le truc qui m'a fait le plus plaisir de ces dix dernières années
J'chuis le frère de Baptiste, tu me reconnais pas?
( Extrait de la vidéo de Baptiste )
"Tu te fous de la gueule du monde toi ou quoi?"
Et ouais mon gars
J'ai rencontré le frère de Baptiste
Et  toi, toi ta rencontré qui?
Ta rencontré Jhonny Depp
Brad Pitt
Mais mec, là on parle du frère de Baptiste
On parle d'une légende
Et le bad c'est que je devais aller voir un truc
et en revenant à l'endroit où je l'avais vu
Il, il était plus là...
(sniffe)
(soupir) Bah bravo, au moins je l'aurais vu n'est-ce es qu'une
un éclair vite fait
Alors si on tape "squeezie est"
"squeezie est un illuminati"
What the fuckk !(rire)
C'est bon ça
Ouais si tu regardes bien dans ce tatouage ya un triangle à un endroit
C'est entièrement faux..
"Squeezie contient 8 lettres comme le mot 'illuminé'
Coincidence?
Je ne pense pas...
Allons voir ça de plus près
Prenons le logo de squeezie
Enlevons le cercle
et trafiquons quelques trucs"
(rire)
J'aime tellement
Bien joué le théoricien
Tu as vu le triangle dans mon logo, bien joué
Alors ya quoi d'autre sinon??
"est mort"
est mort??
"Squeezie nous a quitté à l'âge de 17 ans
En effet, le youtuber est mort en plein vol
lors de son voyage à Madagascar
l'avion a rencontré une banane volante
qui a violement détourné l'appareil
Bilan :
322 survivants
sauf Squeezie et tant mieux"
(rire)
P****n mais internet m'aime
vous sentez? Vous sentez cet amour envers moi
Moi je le sens et..
et c'est ce qui me donne envie de continuer (accent foireux canadien)
Je sais pas pourquoi je fais l'accent québecquois, mais..
Ah p****n
"putain squeezie est riche!!"
( lis les tweets )
Moi non plus ( petit rire )
( lis encore les tweets )
hmmmmmm...
nan... nan nan
(rire)
Nan c'est gentil..mais nan
Euh je fais juste des vidéos hein...
on peux pas, je fais rien d'autre..
Et régulièrement j'appuie sur le toit de cette voiture
(couinement) voilà..
"squeezie est gaucher"
ouiiiiiiii
Rpz les gauchers
rpz les mecs qui galèraient à écrire avec leurs stylos plumes
parce que leur main étalait l'encre..
C'est pour vous (couinement)
"squeezie" attends on a un bien
( lis l'article)
( Extrait de la vidéo sur Pokemon Go )
( Lis encore l'article )
Humour second degrééééé!!!
Il y a un nombre incalculables d'articles comme ça sur le web
sur moi et sur d'autres
Et p***n mais des fois mais pétez un p***n de coup
Arrêtez de défendre à tout prix, tout, tout le temps
même quand de y'a pas de raison
même quand y'a rien à défendre en faite..
C'est juste du second degré
de l'humour
( lis encore l'article )
C'est tellement original de faire un article
en disant que quelqu'un est sexiste et grossier
Alors que c'est une p***n de vidéo humoristique
Cette vidéo part en c*****e
(rire)
Bon clairement en tapant mon nom
on va surtout tomber sur des articles comme ça
ça veut dire que dans les vidéos tu dois te retenir
tout le temps de faire des blagues, des trucs
parce que c'est pas politiquement correct
Franchement je pense que vous me connaissez
vous savez que jamais j'irais offenser
des gens, harceler des gens
faire c***r gratuitement des gens
Bien au contraire je me bats tous les jours contre ça
et je trouve ça un peu triste
que des gens soient autant sur la défensive
tout le temps et qu'ils aient autant besoin de combattre
les choses tout le temps
Y compris des choses qui, des fois n'ont pas besoin
d'être combattues, genre là
c'est juste un vanne dans une vidéo humoristique c'est..stop
ta pas un combat à mener parce que j'ai dis que
la meuf était Ronflex pour la blague
Moi on me traite de squelette et de ficelo
Est-ce que j'en fais tout un plat???
Je m'en bats les c*****e à un moment c'est du second degré
(rire)
Et si t'a rigolé t'es un b****d
P****n c'est nul maintenant
ya que des articles sur euh..
le, les tunes et le..
et le fait que je sois un gros sexiste raciste , fils de p**e
Mais ça on le sait tous déjà
on apprends rien p****n
Bon, on finit sur "squeezie est moche"
c'es pas mal quand-même
Comment on est passé de squeezie est moche à squeezie sexiste
Peut-être que quand t'es moche t'es forcement sexiste du coup j'sais pas
aaaah
"squeezie fait" on l'a pas fait celui-là
"squeezie fait des vidéos"
Là tu t'es trompé de youtuber là
là tu t'es juste trompé de youtuber mon gars
Norman tu pèses tellement que quand un mec fait des vidéos
les gens tapent forcement "nanana fait des vidéos"
"squeezie fait la cuisine"
Là vous vous êtes clairement trompé de personne
"squeezie fait peur"!!!
(rire)
Mais c'est de pire en pire
C'est pour tomber sur mes vidéos de jeu d'horreur
ou genre c'est vraiment un mec qui a peur de moi
et qui cherche des gens qui sont dans la même situation que lui
pour euh.. témoigner
Je te fais peur??
Attends qui apparaît en 1er quand on tape "YouTube"
aaaah...
c'est mon égo, c'est mon égo
Il commence à..
AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAH!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!
Et bah c'est déjà la fin de cette vidéo
Pourquoi j'ai un air sérieux
on sait pas
N'hésiter pas à l'aimer si ça vous a plu et puis,
Ne cherchez pas votre nom sur Google, pourquoi?
Soit ça va flatter votre égo et vous finirez avec votre z**i sur votre propre bouche
sans même vous en rendre compte
Soit ça va le briser en mille
Mais c'est l'un ou l'autre, c'est blanc ou noir
comme dans la tête des gens
qui font des articles pour dénoncer
du sexisme et du racisme là où y'en a pas
Oh il était subtil
Et bien merci d'avoir regarder la vidéo
On se quitte sous cette mine de criterium
qui tombe comme souvent quand t'étais au collège.
et là je galère à la remettre.
comme souvent quand t'étais au collège aussi..
Pourquoi vous êtes encore là??
Sous-titres by ThibGameurTv (et par une fille anonyme <3) (et par Dust :3)